Welcome to Ear Biscuits, I am Rhett.
And I am Link,
this week at our respective
tables of our individual homes.
Yes, we're still at home.
I got to stop saying,
yes, we're still at home.
Hey, we're still at home,
like it's a good thing.
We are discussing the topic
that we've briefly touched on
many times while discussing
other things but we've never
devoted an entire episode
to unpacking this topic
and it's the business side of things,
how did Mythical Entertainment
develop as a company?
Yes, and when we started doing all this,
we didn't have a business in mind.
It wasn't like we're starting a business,
it was, we're gonna create things.
But slowly over the years,
it's gone from two guys
making things on YouTube
to two guys leading a team
of over 80 people, and it's
just definitely a business
at this point, even though
it was never our intention
and we never thought ourselves as CEOs.
So we're gonna unpack that
process and touch on some things
that we've talked about,
briefly will be getting to
some new things, but mainly we
want to focus on the lessons
that we have learned along the way.
And if you're particularly
interested in business,
maybe you own a company of
your own or you aspire to
one day, maybe you can
learn a thing or two
as we share the things that we've learned.
Or if you're really not into
that, we think there's still,
you'd be interested in finding
out the path that we took
and I think there's applications
outside of business as well.
So thanks for coming along
for the ride, no matter what
your interests are.
The truth is we never
thought of ourselves as CEOs
or we never said we wanna
be CEOs, like you said.
But when you talked about
that, it did remind me of
when the Fine Brothers made
that video where kids react
to Rhett and Link and
one kid described you
as the businessman and
described me as the boy.
So we became the
businessman and the boy.
So those are now
our official titles.
Man and the boy.
The official titles, like
when you look at like
a legal document that I have to sign,
it says Rhett McLaughlin the businessman,
and Charles Lincoln Neal, the boy.
And that makes me think,
when we sign things,
technically I'm president
and you're--
You have me
to thank for that.
And you're what?
You're not--
You know why?
I don't even know--
I'm vice president.
Vice president--
You know why?
You have my wife to thank for that
because I was having a conversation
with our very first
lawyer and he was like,
and that was the point in which
I basically, I think maybe
'cause my dad was a law
professor, I just handled
all the business interactions.
I wrote the agreements and--
And I wasn't there.
You weren't there, and he
was like, "Okay, so just for
"legal purposes, one of
you needs to be president
"and one of you needs
to be vice president."
And he was like, "So
just think about that."
And I was like, "Okay."
And so then I'm just telling
Jessie about the meeting
or whatever, and then I'm like,
"So one of us has gotta be
"president, one of us
can be vice president
"and it doesn't mean anything."
'Cause I think we asked could
we be called presidents?
But I think he was like
that's a lot more complicated,
it's not worth it.
Yeah, and we're like 50 50 owners
and we have 50 50 interest and we have,
it's always 50 50 and Jesse was like,
"Well, since you're the
one making the decision,
"you should make Link
president because it would be
"a butthole move to be the
one making the decision
"and to make yourself president."
So now, you're the president
of Mythical Entertainment.
The lesson that I learned is that--
I'm actually the vice
president and secretary.
You don't wanna be the president,
all it means is that I have
to sign more blanks than you
on things that we still both have to sign.
Because that was when we created
our first business entity,
was called RhettandLinKreations,
where the K at the end of
Link became the beginning
of the word creations,
if you misspelled it with a K,
and another lesson learned,
oh, we're full of them,
is that if you name your
business something people can't
understand how to immediately spell,
you're gonna be frustrated a lot.
It's like Rhett and Link
as one word and creations
as part of it, but the K is
shared and I know that's not how
you spell creations.
I mean we've changed the
name of our company to
Mythical Entertainment.
Is it just Mythical now
or it's still technically
Mythical Entertainment?
Business name is still Mythical
Entertainment, but yeah.
And we kept me as the president
so I still got to fill in
a few more blanks than you, but
it's just popping circumstance.
It was actually, it was a
real smart move on my part
'cause I don't like signing things.
But the first real lesson
that we learned beyond those
that I think is what the
operating principle that got us
off the ground as a
business is we had to find
the intersection or the
nexus, if you wanna use a word
like that, of our ability
and our opportunity.
Yeah, we don't need to rehash
how we got from point A
to point B to point C,
from being engineers
to then working for crew and then working,
hosting a television show
called Online Nation.
We shared all of that
in episode one of our
last year's series.
So you can go back and
watch that if you wanna know
how we got from point A
to point B to point C.
But if point C is we're hosting
this show, Online Nation
and it got canceled, we were
flying out to LA to shoot it
and then we find ourselves
back in our little basement
where we were making
videos, back at square one
making videos again but
we had no income anymore.
We just had the money that
we made over that show
and we were living over
that while we figured out
what it was we were going to do,
we had to develop an
entire new business plan.
And there was no, it's important to note,
no one was making money
on YouTube directly,
there was no YouTube partner program.
So you couldn't just
make a video and then see
money roll in.
So really, there was no such thing as
a professional YouTuber.
So it's a really interesting
idea that we were like,
"We're going to have a
career," 'cause we were like,
"Let's make this YouTube
thing a full-time thing,"
but yet no one was making it a career.
But again, we were like,
"What two things exist here?
"We know that we can write
a funny song, we can make
"a funny music video," we
had had success with that,
the Facebook song had gone really big,
and the second piece of the puzzle was,
is we knew that there were
businesses out there who wanted
people to know about them.
So it was like, okay, can we
put those two things together?
Can we put our ability to write
a funny song with a company
that wants to advertise
and put that on YouTube?
And it was really just an
open question at the time.
And there weren't a lot
of big companies that were
sponsoring videos, I think
there was some of that,
it's not like we came
up with the idea out of
absolutely nothing, out of thin air,
but there definitely weren't big companies
investing a lot of money in
this platform where no one
understood YouTube or
digital video that well,
but it seemed like our best play because
the thing that we wanted
to make is the thing that
we could also sell or at
least sell ad space in.
And we thought we could
do a good job of making it
an integration so that
it made sense that the ad
was a part of it.
It wasn't like a lot of videos today where
you will be blogging or
doing whatever you're doing
in your video and then
you can just insert an ad
in the middle and people
would understand that.
And here's a coupon code and here's what,
here's who my sponsor is kind of thing.
So we wanted to do something
that was thoughtful,
that we could be proud
of, but also make money
and feed our kids 'cause we
already had kids at the time.
If you wanna really be driven
to succeeded at business,
have children.
Have children first, yeah.
Have children first, that's right.
'Cause they tend to be
hungry and demanding
and you come home to them and you're like,
man, I gotta get after it.
Well it's one thing to
be a starving artist,
it's one thing to have a starving family.
So when you put, other
people are suddenly,
you're responsible for them,
yeah, that's definitely
a great motivator.
So what we did is we
wrote "The Cornhole Song"
about the classic game,
Bean Bag Toss game,
that was really popular in
the Midwest at the time.
♪ Singing cornhole cornhole ♪
An Olympic sport by 2024,
we're only four years away.
Yeah, we got two more years
to find out.
And we cold called, we
would literally look up
people who were selling
cornhole equipment and
we would just find the
number or the contact email
and we would send a message
or call them.
'Cause they were
internet businesses, it made sense.
They probably will
understand--
And they were small.
An internet video because
they're an internet-based business.
We weren't gonna call like Coke and say,
hey, we've got an idea,
we knew that there was
no way for us to go to
a Fortune 500 company and
get our foot in the door,
but maybe we can find somebody
else who is trying to do
what we were doing.
And after a few different phone calls,
it didn't lead somewhere,
we had talked to a mom
who was selling cornhole
equipment out of her garage
and she was like, "I
love the idea, but I just
"can't afford any advertising."
We finally connected with
the guys at AJJ Cornhole,
who were about our age,
it was three of them,
they were starting their business in Ohio.
They were exactly at the
same place as we were
and they were trying to just
get it off the ground and do
something interesting
and they loved the idea
and they became the
sponsor again, at the time
I wrote the contract up just
based on some guesswork as,
like how much do you get paid to do this?
I don't know, you get some
initial fee and then you get
some money based on
how well that performs,
that makes sense to us.
And it was like they paid
us a few thousand dollars
and then--
And then we came.
We knew that CPMs were a thing.
We knew that there was a
way to get paid based on
performance because of Rever,
that website at the time
was actually paying people
for their videos and their performance,
which no one was watching
our videos over there.
But we knew that there
was the concept of this
cost per million views or
whatever, getting some money back.
So we did that, we wrote a
song about how iPods die,
called "The Dead iPod
Song," we asked our friend,
iJustine to collaborate in the video
so we could get more views.
♪ You pressed the power button ♪
♪ And what happened was nothin' ♪
I think we even shared,
I don't know if we shared
some of the integration fee
with her or if she just did it
as a favor, but it
wasn't that much either--
Oh, I think we did.
iRescue.com repairs iPods,
so that was perfect.
Yeah, they got us off the ground.
They were the only ones besides ourselves
who believed in this.
But then from there, we
got a call to be a part of
an Alka Seltzer campaign, which was
a bonafide ad agency.
Well, that was
a big transition.
That was a big transition.
I think that was
the transition from us
having to go out and find
these people ourselves to doing it the way
that we've done it ever
since, which is fielding
the opportunities usually
either directly from a business
or through an agency.
And that won in 2008, 21
videos for the Alka Seltzer
a great American road trip
where we went along the,
we took an RV trip
across the United States
and made 21 videos that were food themed,
and that was the beginning
of us understanding like,
oh, okay, once you get your
work out there and people see
that you're incorporating
companies into it,
maybe the people will come
to us with the integrations
and that's what happened,
and we basically have
never looked back.
I think that nexus that
you're talking about was that
we were able to do it in
a way that wasn't cringy
and we were communicating
with our audience at the time.
We were telling the Mythical
Beasts, "Hey, we wouldn't be
"able to make this level of
content with this type of
"production value if we
didn't have the sponsors,
"so go support them."
And we're very grateful for the sponsors
and we conveyed that to the audience.
And I think that it was,
it was in no way cringy,
it worked for everybody.
And so it led to more opportunities.
Once you start working with agencies,
that thing starts happening.
When we started making,
I mean, Commercial Kings
wouldn't exist if it wasn't
first for a sponsor, Microbilt.
The CEO was a fan, he started
communicating with us,
he sponsored one little
video, it went well.
So then we hatched the
idea to start making
intentionally bad local
commercials for his customer base
who were small businesses.
And who knew that a few weeks
later you'd be interviewed
on CNN and talking
about selling furniture?
The vice president of
RhettandLinKreations on the line.
So that led to everything,
that led to Commercial Kings,
that led to us moving to California.
So again, I think that if you're
out there listening to this
and you want your particular
skill to be translated
into a business opportunity,
I do think that,
and this is not a simple
question, it's a simple thing
to ask yourself, it's
not a simple thing to do,
but just do you have
something that people,
that you can do, that
you're uniquely good at,
that people are willing to pay for?
And it sounds almost too
simplistic, but we had
to start there because we
didn't have a choice except
to go back and try to use our
engineering degrees again,
which wasn't something that
we were interested in doing.
We got some other lessons,
but first, just wanna give
a quick plug to mythical.com,
we've got lots of
grooming stuff over there.
You can groom your lips with lip balm,
is that considered grooming?
Technically, and I want
to acknowledge that
I may not look like the kind
of person who should represent
grooming as a concept, I
may seem not well-groomed,
but that does not mean
that our grooming products
are not top of the line.
We got pomade, we got
beard oil, we got lip balm.
And they're all incredibly high quality,
they smell good, they make you smell good,
they work effectively.
Try it out.
And they're all available
at mythical.com.
Gifted, rep your boys.
All right, let's get into the next lesson.
I think one of the ways
that we tended to approach
everything, and maybe this
was born out of desperation
a little bit, was we were
always looking for another
opportunity that we could see,
is once people started coming
to us and asking us to do things,
it was not that we said yes
to everything, but that we had
this belief that not doing
something won't lead to anything.
It's doing things that
will lead to things.
I will be more specific
and say that at the time,
we didn't know that we've
learned that lesson looking back,
I don't think we
understood that at the time
because typically, with
a couple of examples
that we'll talk about,
we started to do things
with some intention.
We thought that something
might come from them
and it was very rarely the
thing that we intended initially
that was the result.
It was almost always just
the decision to do something
that then led to the
thing that we actually
ended up doing.
Sure.
I mean, we didn't know
that taking the sponsorship
to make local commercials
would lead to us having
a television show on IFC
and moving to Los Angeles.
But we never would have
realized that if we didn't give
everything we got to those
commercials, some of which
a few of them sucked, but
a few of them really popped
and it made all the
difference in the world.
Good Morning Chia Lincoln
is another great example.
2011, we made the decision
to start what was a daily
show, the two of us sitting
at a card table talking
about whatever we had been
talking about when we came into work.
We made the decision to do
that simply because we had
already decided that we
were gonna go and shoot
Commercial Kings and we
thought, "Well, this might be
"this opportunity to
make a television show
"and we're gonna move to California."
A lot of things were up in
the air, but we knew that
it was a very real possibility.
We didn't know what that
was gonna mean for YouTube,
but one of the things that have
been happening over the past
couple of years on YouTube that
we had never participated in
at all was a regular daily video.
People were doing daily blogs at the time
and their audiences and
their viewers were increasing
exponentially because it
seemed like people wanted
a daily point of contact.
Now we knew he didn't
want to make daily blogs
or family blogs at the
time, but we were like,
"What can we do every single day?"
And the answer was, Good
Morning Chia Lincoln.
But we said from the
beginning that it would end
only as long as a Chia
Lincoln would stay alive,
which is about 40 days apparently,
which is how long the show lasted.
'Cause we knew we'd be
working on the pilot
to Commercial Kings and also
we didn't want people to get
attached to it if it wasn't something that
we were gonna continue forever.
So we just put an end date
at the beginning knowing that
if we wanted to continue it, we could.
Of course we didn't continue
it until after Commercial Kings
wasn't reordered for a second season.
We found ourselves living
in Los Angeles, feeling like
we were back at square one
again, trying to develop
a new business strategy
and that was going back
to sponsorships and get
in that role and again
with music videos, but then
also, developing contact
with the Mythical Beast and re-instituting
Good Morning Chia Lincoln
as Good Mythical Morning.
Again, not knowing what it
would lead to except that
it would span the gaps in between our
high production music videos
where we were actually making money.
Well, one thing I think we did
know, we had begun to learn
that lesson a little bit having done
Good Morning Chia Lincoln and
we knew that people responded
to it and we knew that we were good at it.
We knew that we could sit
down and we could talk about
something for 10 minutes.
We discovered it by trying it.
So when you watch that first episode of
Good Mythical Morning, I
actually saw somebody tweet
just this little slice of the
video, the very beginning of
the video, we're talking
about Good Mythical Morning
in this aspirational way and we're saying,
"We hope that this is the
beginning of something special,
"something that you will make
a part of your daily routine."
And I think the reason
that we were saying that
is because we actually believed it
based on this previous experience.
Then hey, our audience
has connected with this,
and now we're formalizing it
and saying that we're making
an indefinite commitment to
doing the show for however long
and we're still doing it.
And it was based on that
having just made the decision
to do Good Morning Chia Lincoln.
But a huge piece that's
a part of the story is,
we started doing GMM, but then after doing
a couple of seasons of GMM,
YouTube came to us with the
creative innovation program
where they were basically
giving people money to make things.
And we had a pretty good
relationship with YouTube
at the time.
They said, "Hey, do you
guys have any ideas?"
And we reacted to that by
saying, "Yeah, we've got an idea
"to do a variety show
called "The Mythical Show,"
it's a half hour long show
featuring sketch and music videos
and weird games and stuff like that,
taking everything that we
had done thus far on YouTube
and combining it into one product.
And at that point, we
of course needed help
to make the show, so that
was when we hired Stevie,
who they hired some other people to then
build the team out for that
'Cause we had a budget.
All of a sudden, we were
given a chunk of money
for the first time upfront to make,
we were commissioned to make
a show and not just to make
an integration with the sponsor.
YouTube was investing in order
to see what they could learn
from longer form content on the platform.
So we hired Stevie just
to make those 10 episodes
and we also hired her to--
12.
12, and then to build out the team.
So she immediately turned
around and hired Ben,
who's still working for us
and he started to build out
the team from there.
Well I specifically
remember 12 because just
this may be of interest to you
if you're in the video world.
But I remember me and you sat
down 'cause they were like,
"Well, come up with a budget,
how much money do you need?"
And we sat down and we
budgeted everything out.
Now we have been making
videos for nothing.
So we budgeted everything
out and then we added like
a 20% buffer and we still
landed at $100,000 total.
Which may sound like
a lot of money--
For 12 half hour episodes--
But that's nothing for
12 half hour
Is not a lot of money
as we discovered very
quickly for a half hour
of what is essentially
television, which at least
in the first episode,
had a studio audience.
So we quickly took the
studio audience out,
we didn't kill them, but
we took them out because
no one liked it.
We could've probably
benefited from some advice
around pricing of that type of thing
because we had negotiated--
We should have
consulted someone.
Yeah, I mean, Stevie as a
producer, we didn't bring her on
until we had negotiated.
We came up with a budget.
Oh, you know what YouTube
was thinking when we said
$100,000, they were like, "We
could have said $500,000,"
and they would have probably
still thought it was a deal.
We just didn't know.
But we thought just if you
go back, you can still find
the Mythical Show.
There's still our hardcore
fans, still like the show
and see it as a sweet, awesome time
I know you like it.
But the reality is that we
thought that we had come up
with something that wasn't
just a good product.
We thought that we had
come up with something
that was going to change
the landscape of YouTube.
In fact, the tagline of
the show was your half hour
of not having to click
around on the internet.
We thought we were gonna change the habits
of people on YouTube.
And at the time in
2012, people were making
three minute videos.
If you went above three
minutes, it was like,
ah, this is weird, I don't
know if I can hang on.
Nowadays people will make 20 minute videos
and everybody watches them.
But at the time, everybody
was doing these short videos,
so we were going against the grain,
we thought we were gonna
change the way people behaved,
but it didn't happen.
No one really cared about the show beyond
our immediate fan base.
But again, it's the only
reason that we started growing
from that point on because
we had to hire Stevie
who then had to hire a team, and that was
really the beginning of the
totally new phase of business,
which was when we began
to delegate responsibility
and have a team.
Yeah, I think that's
the big lesson that we
had to start learning, which
was we had to learn to trust
others with our vision.
And with Stevie, with Ben, with hiring,
we hired Jen to start
helping tweet for us and do
social media, it's like,
oh, we can't do everything
any more, and we started
building the team from there.
Trust was incremental.
Stevie was gonna do those 12
episodes, but then we started
to discover that, hey,
we work well together.
She brings a lot of strengths,
she thinks through things
in a way that we don't and
she executes things too
in a way that we couldn't,
and it frees us up in a way
that we only dreamed about
or we didn't even give ourselves
permission to dream about.
That was not an easy thing.
No.
And as we've talked to
creators over the years,
especially back on this
podcast, on Ear Biscuits,
when we used to interview other creators,
what we learned is that
this is the common challenge
for every creator, which
is trusting somebody else.
It's something as simple as
trusting somebody with an edit.
If you keep doing it, you're
gonna always be doing it.
It's you never learn to stop,
you never learn that someone
else can do it unless you give
someone else a shot at
doing it and you may have
to go through a few people.
We didn't know that, we didn't know that.
I guess what I'm saying is
I think the Mythical Show
was the beginning of that
lesson learned because
for Mythical Show, we
were over the shoulder
of the editor, we were making
very specific decisions
about the edit, we put our
heart and soul into that.
But then by the time we
got to the end of that,
almost by necessity, we
were like, "This is too much
"content, we can't do everything
"and we can't be
responsible for everything."
And by the way, everything
that Stevie has come in
and contributed to and overseen,
she's done an incredible job.
So then once the Mythical
Show was over and we made
the transition back into
Good Mythical Morning,
it was easy for us at that
point to say, you know what,
I don't think we're going
to actually watch the edit,
'cause this is a daily show,
I mean this is gonna be
a big part of your day if
you're gonna be responsible
for making the show and then sitting down
and helping to put together
the edit and improve the edit.
At that point after the
Mythical Show, we set that aside
and again, we saw the
show continued to grow
and to get better and to grow
audience without having to be
super involved in every single aspect.
Jason, who was working for
us through the Mythical Show
and then when we restarted
Good Mythical Morning,
like I said, we were over
his shoulder like you said,
as he was editing.
So that was an incremental
level of trust, then
with Stevie we were able to
build on that, and then you add
more people to the team and
you start to realize that
people can do things better than we can.
And slowly, you move to a
point where you start to,
we were able to start to
focus on the things that
we wanted to do and the things
that we wanted to bite off
and try to figure out, and
it drove us to trust people
even more because we'd
started to learn that lesson.
And I think that in some ways,
we're constantly learning
and applying that lesson of,
what else do we wanna be doing
with our time that we will be the best at?
What else are we doing
right now that we can ask
someone else to do and
give them an opportunity
to do it better, to delegate?
So it's--
Well, we asked ourselves that question.
I would say one of the biggest exercises,
the most important exercises
that we do every year,
we do it multiple times a
year, but there's a time
every single year where
we sit down and we look at
everything that we've done,
we look back at our schedule
and we think, what did we do
this year that we don't have
to do this year?
What did we do last year that
we don't have to do this year?
So it's like--
And who else can we trust?
At one point it's like
if I'm sitting there and I'm
like, why am I sketching out
a concept for a t-shirt when that's not
what I really wanna be doing right now?
I can get excited about it--
And we're not good at it.
Yeah, we're definitely not as good at it
as Caleb, who's working
for us now and Feldman,
who's working with him
and that entire team
with Dana and then,
hey, you got this team,
you need someone to start
to manage this team.
So you bring in somebody like
Raz and you start to build
a team of people who can
give focus and they can also
pour their passion into it
in a way that we were just
trying to get it done.
And if we pour too much passion into it,
it will be the wrong type of investment.
Well it's the transition from
getting people to do exactly
what you want them to do
to getting them, to inspiring them to do
what they can actually do
better and that they want to do.
And that's been a slow
incremental process,
but now, using Merck as an example, we see
the t-shirt designs when
you see the t-shirt designs,
we see them when they're in
the store most of the time.
And multiple things, it's like
I've got the three different
Good Mythical Morning mugs right here.
And again, these were on the
desk and I know you tend to,
it's more difficult for
you to take yourself
out of the details.
But for me, the first
time I saw these mugs
was when they were on
our desk on the show.
And I saw them once, and I
gave a limited amount of notes
but that was a level of
discipline that I've learned.
And I've also learned to trust them that
they can design something
that is gonna connect
with Mythical Beast
even better than I can.
And that's just something I
had to change my mind about,
and I think it may seem weird to say that,
it's like well people are
attracted to what we're creating
but we just try to be, it's what our,
I'm proud of what we as a team
create, and I also trust them
to come up with the stuff
that's gonna connect
and they prove themselves again and again.
And that doesn't mean we're not involved.
I do wanna,
'cause there is a balance here,
so the thing is that again,
still using this whole
merchandise thing and
really you can use anything
as an example because
we're not making films,
we're making internet content.
So if we see something and it
gets out there on the internet
and then we are like, I
don't like the way that looks
or I don't like the general
direction that this is going,
that's actually where
we get involved because
we are watching a lot of
stuff that we're doing,
we're analyzing people's reactions to it.
And so when we think that
there needs to be a shift
in a certain direction in
any one of these departments,
we do get involved at that
point knowing that hey,
you can course correct,
it's not that big of a deal.
So it's not like we're
completely hands off,
but the development and the
execution of those things
on a very minute level
is something that we have
necessarily removed
ourselves from, and we're
just managing it from
a higher vantage point.
I think you're also
touching on the fact that
we're not just developing
let's say a t-shirt design,
we're developing a t-shirt
designer who can then embody
Mythicality from scratch and
Caleb can express himself
and have fun collaborating with his team
and with his team leader
and present something to us
that is surprising and that connects,
but also sometimes doesn't,
and then that's a lesson,
you can't tell somebody
something and let them learn,
you've gotta experience that,
you learn that as parents,
at some point the kids
gotta jump out of the nest.
I have a nest in the
backyard, I make my kids jump
out of it, it's kind of a bird analogy.
I thought you were
talking about your birds,
I thought you were talking
about your family of birds
that you've been raising.
No, it's my family of humans.
I've to make them to
learn how to jump out of
the metaphorical nest, I pushed
them out of a physical nest
that I've built in the backyard.
That sounds like a product
that we could sell.
Tell me nests.
Think about
Mythical Kitchen.
I think that's another
very current example
of that team
developing content
within certain parameters
and vision that we've helped
set up that in order for
Mythical Kitchen to really
develop a life of its own,
it needs to be an expression
of Josh in that team
working together to passionately
put stuff out into the
world to recreate the
experience that we've had
and we'll continue to have on the content
that we're directly working on.
Not only do they know the kind of content
that would work from a culinary
entertainment standpoint
better than we do because
that's what Josh would have
lives and breathes, they're
also better at executing it.
I think that our role
in that was just knowing
that we wanted to develop our
culinary team to the place
where they're not just making food for
Good Mythical Morning, but they are also,
this is an opportunity
to create content that
a whole new fan or also
existing fans could connect with
because people like this
kind of food-based content.
And then helping to empower
Josh to see his potential as
somebody who could have his own audience.
That was pretty much the
vision, the nebulous vision
that we had.
But then the specific execution
of well, what is gonna be
on the channel and what
the nature of the video
is going to be, that's
the Mythical Kitchen team
with the help of Stevie
leading things creatively
and then working together
as a creative team,
that is something that we're
just shepherding loosely
and it's a better product because of that.
Because as soon as,
I mean, have you spent
a bunch of time watching
recipe videos on the internet?
No, have I?
No.
Maybe more than you have, but not enough,
it's not like I'm an expert on that.
But now we can see what the
content is and we can offer
some feedback, but again
we don't have the time
or the ability, it wouldn't
happen if we insisted on being
the ones who were involved,
it would never happen.
And if it did happen,
it wouldn't be as good
as it is right now.
I think another shift that
we've made, just to move to
a new lesson learned,
is shifting from being
solely reactive to being proactive.
I guess it's not saying much
to say if you're running
a company, you should have
a plan and you should think
into the future.
It's been extremely difficult
as you're walking on the
sidewalk of internetainment,
you can see it forming
right beneath your toes.
There's not a lot of people
that have gone before us
that we can emulate.
So it has been difficult
to take a longterm approach
or to have that proactive
stance when it's like,
I don't know what the next opportunity is
and we just need to say
yes because saying no
leads to nothing.
It's like well, at a
certain point, we got it,
we got to think, more forward.
And as difficult as it is
to develop a three year
or five year plan, we are
getting better at laying out
our longterm vision, knowing
that it's gotta be flexible
given the environment that we're in.
But I think an example of
this that crystallizes it down
is the way that we have grown
in terms of the physical space
that we're in as a team.
So going from, of course
we had the basement
and then the studio and
Fuquay but moving out
to California where all of a
sudden the mortgage on my home
was, or the rent on my home was
five times what the mortgage
on my home in North
Carolina was, or six times,
things were suddenly very
different and it wasn't like,
oh, I can pay this rent and
also we can have a studio.
Like no, we weren't making
enough money for that.
So we thankfully had a garage
that we were in at the time
and of course it was the two
of us and Jason in there,
and then even the first
meeting that we had with Stevie
at her first day of work,
she was in there with us
and we were very quickly
realizing that this is not gonna
cut it, we gotta have a space,
but we're so conservative
in the way that we estimated
what we're gonna have to pay
and we were operating,
I would say fear based.
It was practical, but
it was a little bit like
don't bite off more than you can chew.
So do you remember that
first time that we went out
and looked at different spaces in Burbank
before we found the first spot?
Well, I specifically remember
looking at that place,
I don't know what street
it's on, but it's like
a storefront, it has like a glass front,
it looks like a hair salon and
it's on a major thoroughfare
that people could just
walk in, which incidentally
is what we had in Fuquay, but
Fuquay is not Los Angeles.
And I remember seriously
considering that and of course
what we ended up going with
was a very nondescript place
that no one would ever,
even though people did knock
on the door every once in
a while, I don't even know
what that place was, but--
Downstairs is where we had
a room to build a set for
Good Mythical Morning.
Set is a very loose term there.
It was a dedicated place
where we could go downstairs
and film episodes of the show
and then we could go back
upstairs and just work at our
desks, 'cause it's not like
we had to turn the camera
in and it's not like we had
to set up the camera
so that our desks were
in the background, this
was definitely a step up.
And we got to a place
within a few years of being
in that spot where everyone
was working pretty much
on top of one another.
We had not literally stacked
desks on top of each other,
but that was the only
logical place to go next.
And so we were like, "Okay,
let's look for a new space."
And do you remember the place that we were
very close to renting?
Yeah, the guitarist for the doors,
the Jim Morrison band, the
doors was renting a storefront.
We never met him, but the
agent showed us around
and in the back, it was
just like a cement slab
and it was on air
conditioned, but we were like,
"Well, we can build two sets back here."
I mean it's on air
conditioning so it's gonna get
to like 110 degrees.
It was very warehousing.
It had a giant beam that went through,
there was a giant beam
that went through it,
remember there was this
conversation about what we could do
with that giant beam
'cause it was gonna be
in all the shots, it was--
It was just storage.
They were shipping
stuff, they had shelving,
it would've been horrible,
it would've been a downgrade,
but we were seriously considering it.
But we were, no, we weren't
just seriously considering it,
we got down to the place where we said,
"If this guy is willing to do this,
"if the landlord is willing
to do this one alteration,
"then we'll rent it."
In the meantime, while we
were waiting on an answer back
for that, we went to the
studio that we're currently in
and now this was a legitimate studio.
It had a real set with soundproofing,
television shows had
been shot on this set.
It had a recording studio,
it had all these things
that we needed and wanted,
but we were looking at it not,
we weren't really looking
at it to consider it,
we were looking at it
because our realtor like,
"Here's another spot, this is
way out of your price range,
"but you should look at it just and see
"that what's available."
And I remember walking around
our space and thinking,
man, this is awesome, but I can't imagine,
I can't imagine filling
this place up with people,
I can't imagine getting to a,
how could we ever get to a
place where we would have
enough people to work in this place?
And then I think me and
you were on the same page,
which was we can't afford
this and it's too big,
and then Ben, who was
working for us at the time,
I remember he pulled us
aside and he was like,
"Guys, I know that the
place that we looked at,"
'cause everybody, we all went
together to look at the places
'cause it was our very small team.
"I know that the place
that we looked at yesterday
"is like the Ferrari of
studios, at least in our minds."
"And I know that it seems
like it might be too much,
"but I just wanna say that,"
I can't remember his exact
words, but it was essentially,
I know that we could use it
and I believe that we could
do great things there.
And I just want to,
almost from a technical perspective
as your cinematographer,
the guy who makes things
look a certain way,
I just want to let you know
that this would be the real deal
and we ended up doing it.
And it made a difference.
And he was right.
We ended up, when the other
side of the building came up
for lease, we had a different mentality.
We were like, "Okay when
would there be an opportunity
"to rent the contiguous space
and double our capacity,
"it will not happen again if
somebody else scoops this up."
So it was like that really worked out.
Well, we didn't have an idea at the,
again by that time like you
said, our mentality had changed.
We got into the space, we
used it, we quickly got to
capacity there 'cause that
seems to be what always happens.
And then when that space
next door became available,
we didn't have any plans for expansion,
we didn't have any
specific ideas to fill it,
but it was one of the first
things that we've done
that was a bigger risk
that was very proactive.
And it wasn't waiting for
somebody to come along
with an idea or an opportunity
that we can then execute
in that space, it was very
much, let's get the space
and let's expect the opportunity.
And lo and behold, right
after we started renting it,
like literally months after we
made the decision to rent it,
YouTube came along and said,
"Hey, we wanna fund a bigger
"version of GMM," and that
was when all of a sudden
we had to hire like 50
people and we had to put them
somewhere and lo and behold,
we had the space next door.
And just to move on to the next lesson,
it's interesting how our
culture evolved and how
our understanding of what
it meant to be leaders
in a growing company and
how to tackle the challenges
of actually providing leadership and how
to give our vision to our
employees and then empower them
and then just shape a culture
where we could continue
to work together and achieve
our goals and also the ideas
that they could come up with.
There was a lot of adjustments
in there that we really
started to come to grips with.
We are running a business
here and I think a lot of
the culture.
The lesson very specifically
is that we learned
that we had a culture.
That wasn't something that
we had ever thought about.
We had been two guys who
were executing a vision,
trying to create things and
hiring people to contribute
directly to that and
empowering them and delegating.
But it wasn't until we
got to about 20 people
when it started to really hit us.
I remember, we were
still doing things like,
still doing the books ourselves and just
it was like we were unwilling
to admit that we had
a business, it was a small business,
but we had a small business
and that intentionally
or otherwise, we had
established a certain culture
and people could read it,
but it wasn't something
that we were doing on
purpose, it was something
that was just happening
based on our personnel.
And I think when we hired
Brian, a very strategic hire
for us as our chief operating officer
and head of business
development, he was able to bring
a perspective into all of the
conversations that we would
have in terms of opportunities
to start to understand
and reshape our culture.
Because we had this family atmosphere when
you would just hire people
and they would be just as much
friends as they would be employees.
And like you said, when
you get to about 20 people,
we personally don't know what
every person's working on
from day to day, we're
zoomed out from that.
And we started to become
interested in instituting
another level of accountability
where it's not just,
hey, if we hire you, you're
a member of the family,
no matter what, basically,
accountability was lax
and there wasn't specific goals in mind.
So there was a shift that Brian
really helped us lock into
from moving from a family
culture to a team culture.
And that can sound, just
wanted to acknowledge,
that may sound, oh, that
sounds a little bit harsh,
you mean it's not a family anymore?
But I think that, this
was a helpful way for me
to understand it because
I was initially resistant
to the idea because we're
nice guys and we're actually
pretty conflict avoidant and
we're very loyal and I think
that those can be good
to a certain degree.
But what we were finding is
that if you think about a family
like, okay, here in my
family, especially as we're
isolated here, it's like
everybody's expected to do things,
the kids have their days
where they're supposed
to clean their rooms or
unload the dishwasher
and they don't always do that.
No, they don't do that.
Does that mean...
And even if one of my kids
decided that they were gonna
refuse to ever do their part,
will they no longer be my son?
No, they're still gonna live
here and we'll get through it,
they're still a part of the family.
But if you run a business
like that, you run into
some pretty obvious problems.
But if you shift to a
team mentality, it's like,
okay, when you think about
an athletic team, it's like,
okay, the people who are on
the team are the ones who
believe in the vision, are team players,
but also can execute and do things well.
It's like you get to be a
part of the starting five
if you're one of the best
players and you get to be
actually on the team if
you're a contributing player.
And if you can't contribute
or if you just refuse,
there's no birthright to
being a part of the team,
it means that we might have
a difficult conversation
and we might have the ultimate
difficult conversation
which is to say we're
gonna have to part ways.
And I think we learned that
there is such a thing as
a cultural fit that not every
single person that we think
will work will work.
And just as often, that person
will be the one to discover
what I'm actually interested
in and what I'm most gifted at
and where I want to invest my
passions is not in alignment
or it doesn't, it's not,
I'm not a puzzle piece
that fits here.
As we started to discover that,
we started to set expectations.
So when we would bring
someone new onto the team,
we would say, "Okay, our
policy is there's basically
"a six week trial.
"At the six week mark, we're
gonna have an assessment
"and it's gonna be a
conversation both ways,
"just to know if this
is gonna work or not."
Because you just can't hire somebody even
in the most diligent way and
know if it's gonna work out.
It's not reasonable, but I
think that we were bringing
this mentality that, hey, if you're here,
you're here for life.
And we got that feedback from
some people that we brought on
on a contract basis just
to work, or that's how
they wanted to work,
especially in this town.
So we learned from that and
I think we started to benefit
from that expectation that six weeks down,
we're gonna have this assessment to see
if this is a good fit for everyone.
Well, another piece of that
is this idea of very direct
candid communication, and
continues to be a difficult thing
for us to do just
naturally because we're not
those kinds of bosses.
But it's an important thing
again if you're the coach
of a team and you're watching
your player do something
or you're watching the tape
back, you wanna be like,
hey, come here, take a look at this,
you see what you did there?
I'd rather you do this.
That's not the way you
communicate with your family
'cause if you do, if you try to,
and I'm guilty of this
sometimes and I'm sure
you are as well.
Sometimes I'll go into business
leader mode in my family
in trying to get my kids to
do things and it doesn't work
in a family atmosphere
where everybody knows
that they're gonna be here forever.
But on the team atmosphere,
it's like, hey listen, no,
this is actually your
compensation and your longevity
at this company are based
on your contribution
to the bottom line in a lot of ways,
and so we're gonna have to have
some difficult conversations
from time to time and
that that can become just
an expectation and a part of your culture,
the healthier everything's
gonna be, not easy to get there.
I think we got into problems
when we wouldn't think
someone was a good fit
or they wouldn't beat
their performance, just
consistently wouldn't meet
our standards or our goals,
then it was hard to have
those conversations.
But when we didn't have them
and we skirted the issue,
it made everything worse.
And then we're talking about partying ways
and somebody feels blindsided
and sometimes you have to
learn lessons, we had
to learn some lessons
in a more painful way.
And there's a right way to talk about it,
but not talking about it is bad news.
I think another thing that we
had to come to grips with was
we couldn't just lead by osmosis of
what our demeanor was and the
fact that we would show up
as performers because people
would interact with us
when we were performing,
shooting Good Mythical Morning
and other things.
But there was also an interaction
that we needed to have
as leaders and being
visible as our company grew,
especially to 80 people of,
okay they are providing
leadership, I understand what this
company is ultimately
interested in and made up to be
and what is the culture
and what's the vibe and
what does the company care about,
because what do Rhett and Link care about?
And do they care about me?
All of those things led to
making practical decisions like
having a company-wide meeting every month.
That for month after month,
we would have to convince
ourselves that we needed
to keep having it because
we had to realize there
was value in everyone
hearing from us and then
realizing there's things
that we could bring to the table
in terms of giving perspective
on here's an anecdote
that we heard from a Mythical Beast.
We're gonna share it with all
of you in order to help you
understand the difference
that all of the work
that we're doing makes in people's lives.
Even if some people knew it
here or there, it's helpful
for them to hear it from us
and just to hear and experience
our passion for what we're working on.
But also to have a little bit
of fun, I mean I don't know
how we started opening every
meeting with people share
if they've had a run in with
a celebrity, like a fight,
like a lot of people who work for us,
they get in brawls with celebrities.
No, they just spot celebrities.
So I wouldn't call that a running.
I think somebody just told a
story at one point and then,
yeah, now it's how we open every meeting
and there's always,
when you got a company that
size and you're in Los Angeles,
without fail, someone has seen
a celebrity and it's almost
always a funny interaction or a situation.
And it's fun and it's connecting.
And then we go through an agenda
of all the different areas
and what milestones and
things that we're excited
about night, and it took
a while for us to realize
that there was value in that.
It took us awhile to realize
there was value in it
because again, there's been a
slow transition over the years
of us seeing what we were
building at Mythical Entertainment
as a vehicle to allow us to
do the things that we were
most creatively excited about.
Again, we didn't get in
this to be business people,
we got in this to be creators.
But then once you realize
you've got this business
that needs to be led and
you have to be involved,
sometimes you have to say,
okay, well I'm actually
not going to be able to
just throw myself into this
creative project and just be
the artist guy all the time
that can come in when he wants to
and just waits until he's inspired.
It's like, no, you actually
have to provide the structure
and the leadership for
a company to be healthy.
And so those are two different things
in two different modes.
And so a lot of this just
comes down to scheduling for us
and making sure that, okay,
now we've got the meeting,
we gotta be ready for it.
Do you think that when we
have our company wide meeting
and there's the big boardroom table
and everybody's around the
table and then in the bleachers
behind the table and
here we are both seated
next to each other, shoulder
to shoulder, behind the table
facing them, not unlike, we
would sit behind the GMM desk
and then there's like the
business banter version
of Good Mythical Morning,
I wonder if they feel like
it's a bit of a business show.
Not that it's fake or that it's insincere.
I don't think they would
think that, but just that it's
a bit like the business version of GMM.
I'm sure that it's a little
unusual for like an intern
who has been watching the
show and then they come to the
first meeting and, oh they're
just sitting at a desk
like they do other shows.
I've never really thought
about it, but yeah,
but it's not as entertaining as the show.
No.
For sure.
And it doesn't need to be,
that's not what it's about.
I'd say another aspect of this is that,
so we're still learning a
bunch of lessons about that,
about what it means to try to
be creative and try to lead
a company and we have a lot to learn.
But because we have sorted
out some of this and learned
some of these lessons and put
some of these things in place
and we felt like we had gotten
to a place where it was like
there's a nice balance of
having creative freedom
but being able to provide
leadership but also being able
to entrust people to lead
teams really efficiently
and to create a great product,
that made the decision to
acquire Smosh last year
an easier decision for us.
Again, not something
we ever set out to do,
we never thought we
were gonna be acquiring
other internet businesses.
And even if you had to ask us
at the beginning of the year
that we did that, we would
have been like, you know what,
that's not something we're interested in.
It was serendipitous,
we told that story about
how everything aligned up perfectly.
But because we had a culture
and we had a system in place,
it wasn't that big of a
stretch to incorporate
a whole other team, a whole
other company into our company
and apply a lot of the same
principles because we had gotten
to a place where we were
comfortable with people
who had their own creative vision.
In fact, that was what we were after.
And we just were like, but
here's the business structure
and the production side of
things that you can put in place
to make your content dreams come true,
but you guys are the ones
that are gonna have to be
in charge of the creative,
you know your fan base,
you've got more subscribers
than we do, you've been doing
this for longer than us.
And that was an interesting
experiment of just being able
to say, all right, let's take
the things that we've learned
and apply those lessons
to this acquisition.
But we've already got creatively motivated
people in place and I think
that that's one of the reasons
that it's worked so well for both sides.
And I think hearing feedback
from Ian and from Smosh,
it makes me feel good when
they talk about the contrast
from their experience before to being
under the wings of Mythical
because they describe it as
a different experience being
in a creator led company.
And I really think it comes down to,
there's definitely business accountability
and there's lots of structure
and there are of course
corporate aspects to what we do now,
with these many people, there has to be.
But it's all built on the
foundation of belief that
if you're passionately
expressing yourself in a way
that's committed to reaching your audience
and connecting with them
honestly, and you've got
a proven track record,
that's earned trust.
So the creative quotient is
a lot higher than in some
companies where it's just, okay, we might,
I don't know how other companies
would do it in terms of
how they would calculate and
factor in creative decisions.
But there's just a level
of trust and belief there,
subject to parameters and
this doesn't just apply
to Smosh, it applies to us
and we just convey it to them
as well that that's what leads to success.
You can't underestimate
the creative component
and the passion involved in it.
And the latest aspect of this,
recognizing that you have
a culture, embracing that
culture and trying to shape
that culture that's been
put into a bit of a test
with what's happened with the coronavirus
and we're very much as you
can tell by the fact that
we're at home, we're obeying
the social distancing
requirements and no one
is working at the office,
everybody's working from home.
And that's created its
own unique challenges from
a technical perspective,
which we've overcome,
but it's been a unique
challenge in terms of
the cultural aspect of the
company because what is the
culture now when everyone
is just at home all day
and communicating via video conference?
So I think one of the things
that we decided to do early on
is like, well let's have
our company-wide meeting,
but let's do it as a big
Zoom call and everybody's
gonna be on there, and it was
interestingly or surprisingly
connecting and we got a lot
of feedback from people.
We did the thing that we
always do, we started it off
asking people to tell
celebrity spotting stories.
There was actually one, somebody
saw John Ham on a balcony,
and it's like it's a sort
of a different flavor
when we're all social distancing.
But what we realize is that
having made the decision
to set up this regular touch
point where we're communicating
with our company and our
company is communicating
with each other, it wasn't a
difficult thing to carry that
into this weird time,
that we're just talking
on video conference.
But there was an added
weight to it just coming
to the realization that
this was a leadership moment
where we could communicate
what the plan was
and give as much as we could,
a sense of security like
okay, we are moving forward.
This is a difficult and trying time
but we're in this together.
So yeah, there was, it's like
I feel needed as a leader,
I feel like this is
an opportunity for us and it's not easy.
I think when you look at
this scenario or looking back
on everything, there was never a point
where we felt fully ready.
Saying that we were blindsided
by the CEO ness of it all
is something that you
just, you take every day
and you take every
opportunity for what it is
and we learn from our mistakes and
we try to learn from everything.
I think these lessons
again are still for us
as we're continuing to
learn and hone those and...
I don't know, especially in
light of what we're dealing with
now, I just have this added perspective of
it's a privilege to be
able to lead a company
even though I never
knew I wanted to do that
and sometimes it's still very frustrating
and it doesn't seem like the
main thing that I wanna be
working on, I do have this sense that
it's not only a weighty obligation,
but it's a privilege to do that
and to shape a culture and a
company that not only cares
about what we're creating,
but it cares about,
and we care about all the
people that we're working with.
And as certainly, I'm as
grateful as I've ever been
for everybody who works for us,
given what we're going through right now.
And I think that's a
good way to wrap it up
with one final lesson, and that is,
we're having to learn to always
be looking for the lesson
that we're currently learning.
A lot of these lessons are
things that you don't see them
until you look back until
there's some perspective
after the fact.
But I think that over time
you get a little bit better
at being like, oh,
actually, there's a lesson
happening right now.
If I can actually figure out
what it is and anticipate it
and learn it right now, then
we can begin to apply it.
And I think that this
crisis and this change,
the way that our company
has been forced to adapt,
we're learning new lessons.
The big thing that we've been trying to do
in more recent years is figuring
out what does Mythical mean
beyond just the two of us?
What does it mean in terms of content?
What does it mean in
terms of just the company
and the leadership?
And there's only so much that
the two of us can accomplish
as leaders and as creators,
but the concept of Mythical,
thanks to our incredible team and also to
the incredible fans who have
bought into what we're doing.
It's given us, we're learning
this lesson that hold on,
whether we want it to be or not,
this is already bigger than us.
But how do you manage that
wisely and how do you continue
to grow it in a way that it doesn't lose
what makes Mythical Mythical
and continues to give us
opportunities to, we still want
to personally create things
that are awesome.
We're not done creating new things.
It's not like we're about
to walk off into the sunset
and say, hey, this is what
we've made and now we're done,
we still, and we probably
always will think this way,
we still think our best
work is ahead of us.
But also, we've been forced
to embrace the fact that
oh, this Mythical thing is
just happened and it has
a lot of potential, let's do
this wisely, let's deliver.
I think our best work now
that we come to grips with it
also includes prioritizing
not only our own health,
but the health of our team,
that they're not just employees,
but they're people.
And if creating a
culture is something that
I am increasingly passionate about
because it's a great opportunity
and also to continue to make
things that make a difference.
It's not just making
this stuff we wanna make,
but making it in a way that
continues to make a difference
in people's lives and like
you said, continuing to learn
lessons along the way from
not only our successes
but our shortcomings.
So it's an amazing position
that we find ourselves in
and I'm very grateful for it.
Very.
You got any other lessons
or you just have a wreck?
Oh, yeah.
Well just to get very practical,
at the top of the year,
we took all of our team
leaders and we said,
"Let's go through a book
together that we can discuss
"in how we can all be better leaders."
And so I recommend that book to you,
it's called "The Making of
a Manager" by Julie Zhuo,
last name is spelled Z-H-U-O.
If you're interested in
tackling some of those issues
about how to inspire the
best and as you manage people
or manage people who manage people
or you're managed by people,
"The Making of a Manager" is
my recommendation.
And I think it's
very helpful, especially for
people who find themselves
thrust into a new position
of having to lead,
which is something that starts
happening as companies grow.
You go from everybody doing
their own thing to like,
oh, now I've got a team.
It's super practical,
easy read, very helpful.
I also recommend it.
Well, thanks for coming on
this business journey with us,
use hashtag EarBiscuits as always
to continue the conversation.
I'm curious what stood out to
you or how our conversation
has been mirrored in your own
experience, or I just gave you
food for thought even outside
of the business world.
And also let us know just
as a concept of getting into
this kind of thing, which as
Link hinted at the beginning,
it isn't necessarily for everybody,
not everybody is directly
interested or involved
in this kind of thing.
But did you find this information
intriguing or interesting,
even if you don't have
a business of your own?
'Cause we could keep talking about lessons
that we're learning in the future.
All right, well, we'll
speak out to you next week.
You're fired!
Just kidding.
I've never actually said that to anybody.
To watch more Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist on the right.
To watch the previous
episode of Ear Biscuits,
click on the playlist to the left.
And don't forget to click
on the circular icon to subscribe.
If you prefer to listen to this podcast,
it's available on all your
favorite podcast platforms.
Thanks for being your Mythical Beast.